ces manifestations date de 2016
opération lukoil dans le centre
manifestation devant la mairie de
fort-de-france
aujourd'hui c'est un ras-le-bol donc on
vient défendre nos droits pour pouvoir
aider la population
il y a aussi cette irruption dans une
réunion des maires au lamentin pour
réclamer le paiement de leurs
cotisations
il faut cinq ans vient supplier et lui
verser leurs cotisations
cette mobilisation dure trois semaines
un mécontentement qui finit par porter
des fruits
le 29 février 2016 cette signature
suspend le mouvement aujourd'hui nous
avons eu des réponses sur quelques
questions énormément question qu'ils
devront être abordés par en est il mais
en novembre 2016 c'est la déception des
actes de bonne volonté qui
malheureusement ne sont toujours pas
appliquées aujourd'hui 45% des communes
n'ont pas payé leur cotisation 2016 et
la majeure partie des communes
redevables n'ont toujours pas réglé leur
hargne et ris trois ans se sont écoulés
que s'est il passé depuis des
réalisations déjà dans les cartons
depuis des années ont été finalisés de
nouvelles casernes celle des trois îles
et du lamentin de rivière salée ont été
inaugurées l'an dernier depuis cette
commune ont une caserne neuve
trois nouvelles constructions devraient
débuter l'an prochain il y a eu des
recrutements mais pas de création de
postes selon les syndicats
aujourd'hui de nombreux problèmes
demeurent et les pompiers sont de
nouveau dans la rue agacé des
difficultés de fonctionnement au
quotidien
le matériel d'intervention et le parc
des véhicules sont vieillissants alors
il faut comprendre que le personnel 10
aujourd'hui et ça tue et on en a marre
parce que ça fait un moment qu'on
signale à la direction qui a trop de
problèmes début avril 2019 suite à un
préavis de grève de nouvelles
discussions débutent avec quelques 80
points de revendication le retard des
salaires d'avril dernier déclenche outre
des protestations de vraies
interrogations mais fatigué on a débuté
là on est à bout et la vraie question
qu'on se pose actuellement 6 quelle est
l'importance des sapeurs pompiers dans
le territoire martiniquais quel est
notre rapport au temps ce quelles
valeurs nous accorde et les politiques
et les lmr les élus et tous nos
responsables ou que depuis plus d'une
semaine soyons dans la rue en train de
quémander une optimisation et une
commande et de perfectionnement de
secours martinique
des interrogations qui concerne la
gestion des finances du sdiss le stis
souffre d'un problème de trésorerie
d'une sous dotation depuis sa création